we were joined by Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo he was sworn in as Secretary
of State April 26 2018 he previously
served as director of the CIA from
January 2017 to april 2018 secretary
Pompeo thank so much for joining the
show again it's great to be back with
hope you're doing well
hanging in there so secretary Pompeo
let's talk a little bit about the
foreign policy angle on all this we've
seen tremendous turmoil globally in the
midst of all of this we're all focused
obviously on locking down and staying
safe and trying to follow all the
guidelines and regard to social
distancing but we've seen incredible
turmoil internationally let's begin with
China so China is in large part
responsible for the spread of this virus
they knew there was human human
transmission weeks before they informed
the rest of the world of this five
million citizens left Wuhan province
well apparently they knew that this
thing was spreading what sort of
measures should the United States be
looking to take in the future to either
seek recompense from the Chinese
government or to protect ourselves from
from future situations like this then
you've got both of those facts right two
missions first to hold accountable the
parties responsible for the deaths here
in the United States from the enormous
economic cost that has been posed on the
United States and frankly you talk about
the international implications the whole
world the entire global economic system
the ecosystem all around the world has
been decimated ways we've not seen in
our lifetimes so the United States is
engaged in a handful things one
diplomatically we're reaching out to
countries all across the world to help
them do the right things to help their
economies get started back up to make
sure that when the time is right we get
international travel kick backed up so
that global commerce can wreak commence
and get the man back up that'll matter
an awful lot to workers right here in
the United States of America we're also
working with those countries to make
sure they understand that this was in
fact a virus that originated in Wuhan
China that the chinese government knew
about this certainly by December of 2019
and that they failed to comply with
their most fundamental obligations as a
nation and importantly to sell to comply
with the international health
regulations of the World Health
Organization and then did a lot of
things so when you can talk about them a
great lengths to cover that up those are
the kind of things that we need to
address when the president talks about
the fact that when I can underwrite the
world health
organization not that attempted to
punish anyone it's an attempt to say my
goodness this mission failed this this
organization failed in its mission to
protect the world from this global
pandemic we're not going to let that
happen again and we're going to set up
something a system which delivers an
outcome which reduces the risk that
anything like this can never happen
again from China or from any place else
Secretary of State Pam Payeur do you
think that the United States needs to
take a more skeptical view of business
doing business in China over the long
haul particularly in fundamental
industries like the manufacture of masks
for example in this particular case
medical equipment defense equipment
given the fact that China basically
broke a huge number of supply chains and
that is part of the reason why you've
had this complete breakdown in global
product movement then of course that
good common sense in fact this is
something the president has been talking
about since he came to office something
I'm given speeches on over the last two
years the the nature of the trade
relationship between the United States
and China has been fundamentally broken
for a long time no administration before
ours has been willing to confront that
the sale to protect intellectual
property we failed to make sure that we
protected those industries here in the
United States that needed that for our
national security you see an example
there with respect to issues that
preserve our capacity to respond to
global health crises but those are
there's a broader set of national
security implications there as well and
then I would say to business leaders all
around the world and I hear it from them
to small medium businesses operating a
chairman even the world's largest
businesses
I think they now can see the political
risk associated with operating in China
when the Chinese Communist Party refuses
to uphold basic norms of transparency
basic set of functions that preserve
human rights and the things that need to
happen just to make sure the globe
doesn't end up in crises like that I
think out of their own economic interest
they're going to make very different
decisions going forward I think that's
completely appropriate for them to
evaluate that we're suing the Secretary
of State
Mike pumphouse secretary Pompeo
obviously in times of great economic
turmoil like this there's the
significant possibility that economic
turmoil turns into actual military
turmoil we've seen that Iran
starting to get aggressive again they
are starting to harass ships again makes
perfect sense when you consider that
Iran was already on the ropes now the
oil price has dropped in some cases
below zero and futures contracts which
means that they basically have no source
of revenue at this point how should the
United States be treating Iran generally
how should the United States be treating
around with regard to aid for for a
coronavirus for example I mean obviously
their citizens are human beings and we'd
love to see those people survive it's
not their citizens fault their
government is a bag of garbage but how
should the United States be treating the
Iranian regime right now and and what do
you see is the risk from the Iranian
regime toward other actors in the region
been president and his team been working
on the problem that in the Islamic
Republic Iran we identified them early
on as the largest force for instability
in the Middle East
there's many challenges there but it has
been this country that has been the
world's largest at state-sponsored
terror for many many years so our
mission set was very clear
we began by tearing up the Iran nuclear
deal it was a disaster in many
dimensions and will begin to strip away
the things that provided resources for
the Iranian regime that's different from
humanitarian assistance when the Cobra
Dwight situation broke out the United
States immediately offered to provide
humanitarian assistance to Iran not
surprisingly perhaps the regime that
cares less about its people than it does
about fomenting terror around the world
rejected the u.s. offer veldt so the
effort must continue we have to continue
to deny this regime the capacity to
inflict harm around the world and I'll
add one more thought to Ben this is
connected to China - China has been one
of the countries that has continued to
take oil from Iran even in the light of
the terror campaign that they've engaged
in the Iranians even today are working
alongside the Chinese on a
disinformation campaign authoritarian
regimes in times of crisis tend to work
together you seen - China become
aggressive even during this crisis
moving ships into the South China Sea
taking down a fishing vessel in the
South China Sea
these Authority regimes are the kinds of
regimes that hope to benefit in times of
crisis in this case of crisis that
emanated from one of their countries the
free world the democratic nations of the
world need to work together to push back
against this it's
important time not only to respond to
the virus - but to respond from
increased belligerency from these
authoritarian regimes meanwhile
Secretary of State Pompeii oh because of
the giant decline in oil prices there's
speculation that that might be putting
some American allies at risk even non
democratic allies like like the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia the possibility that as
that as that kingdom begins to falter in
terms of its ability to to make money
off of the toil that that regime could
fall into instability one of the
long-standing American concerns has been
that if the if the if the rulership of
Saudi Arabia were to fall it would be
replaced by a much more radical
leadership is that of a increasing
concern given the economic circumstances
right now that's a great question
we're watching closely in multiple
places around the world the impact of
the fall in oil prices countries whose
revenue was 80 or 90 percent dependent
on flows from oil prices sales of crude
oil we're also seeing increased food
security risks in those countries as
well some of them may seem far away but
that instability in some of those
nations has the ability to impact the
United States and keeping our people
safe president roza made clear our
primary function of course is to protect
Americans first but those kinds of
instability because that risk that
they'll be increased terror threats
increased global terror campaigns we're
watching them closely throughout the
Middle East
I do concern I do think Americans should
be watching to see how the challenge of
a very very low historically low crude
oil prices can lead to food insecurity
and disruption and instability in places
that matter an awful lot to American
security Secretary of State pompeya that
does raise the question as to how vital
it is that America reopened as soon as
possible there was a report from the
United Nations that if the world economy
doesn't begin to move again that you
could see tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions people on the brink
of starvation there are people who are
living marginally right now as the
supply lines break down their food
simply goes away how vital is it for the
United States to reopen and how fast do
you think the United States
realistically is going to reel but what
does that really look like well second
what the Vice President the Task Force
have said we need to get the American
economy spark back up just as quickly as
we can
I will obviously do so in a way that is
safe but I
talk to folks back in my home state
again there they're ready to go they
want to get back out engage in the world
they want to do so in a way that
reflects the risk but they also know
there's enormous risk to their
communities to their hometowns and I can
see from a global perspective the
massive poverty the massive destruction
of wealth that will be created if we
can't figure out a pathway to get our
economies back up and functioning we
left a time where the United States
economy was on fire the global economy
in many places was doing very well we
need to do everything we can to work
towards doing that getting that back
going we're going to do our part of the
State Department we're going to help
these countries organize get their
systems right make sure we get the
international component of this right so
American business people can travel and
goods can flow freely across oceans and
air transport can take place all of
those things need to come together and
it's imperative that we do so as quickly
as we can a a massive global recession
is not safe or secure for the American
people we've got to get our country and
others back open as quickly as we can't
Ben well Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
really appreciate your time thanks for
the work that you're doing in this
difficult time and us stay safe out
there sir
thank you Ben do you do the same so long
sir
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content